the best joke I ever played on my kids
I'll tell you why this is my favorite
because I didn't even pull it on them
they pulled it on themselves we were at
Petco and my daughter walks up to me she
was probably five or six and she walks
up and she's just
I know I didn't eat my breakfast
I know I know I didn't I know I didn't
eat my breakfast and I promise you when
I get home I will eat my breakfast I
promise you
but
can I have a cookie
and I go babe I don't have any cookies I
didn't bring any cookies it's morning
time she goes no no no no I want one of
the Petco cookies
show me what you're talking about show
me right now
now for those of you who have never been
out of the house before to a Petco
you don't know these big giant open bins
of dog treats and some of them look
exactly like
chocolate chip cookies
so she walks up and she goes I go
you wanna
you wanna eat that cookie
and she goes
and I go
foreign
about it you want a cookie
and he goes yeah I go okay
now my oldest son is probably seven or
eight
and he's looking at them but he's not
taking his eyes off of them
and he's talking to me and he goes
that's dog food right
[Laughter]
and I said yeah yeah
and then I said to him
do you want a cookie
we were poor man so they it was a cruel
trick they they they my rule at my house
was that like yo man if I give you a
treat and you don't finish it you don't
get that treat again well I didn't think
of these as treats I thought of them as
a joke but they thought them as treats
so they both just popped them in their
[__] mouth and I was like
and if I had to choose not choose one
word to describe a Petco cookie ladies
and gentlemen it's moist yeah
you aren't laughing are either children
or don't have kids ah
[Music]
bring it
[Applause]
[Music]